is that why there's sort of a thin line
between friendships and then business
contacts or work relationships in this
industry and how do you not blur the
lines there well there's a very thin
line between friendships and business
relationships and I think that
especially an independent film
specifically it's very easy for those
two things to blend I'm not saying or
advocating for you to be completely
distance with everyone you work with you
it's okay to be friendly and accessible
and and and friends with the people you
work with but you can't allow your
friendship to lose sight of the
professional things that have to occur
and that may mean that someone you work
with does something wrong or does
something bad and you have to reprimand
them for it if your friendship and your
professional life are so intertwined
that you can't have a serious
conversation with them without them
being upset or offended or whatever it
is that's not a healthy professional
relationship because then you can't
distill those two things you've really
got to make sure that when you're
working with people that you're enabling
yourself to to have those lungs drawn
you